[Music]
do you guys know who is Remillard is
Ezra Ezra sounds like the singer but not
right yeah oh he was an actor who's this
he's an actor he's the flash he's been
in fantastic beasts
what is this have a jawline like that
does it good looking guys hey he
practices great tongue posture that's
right mummy I do that mewing mewing
mewing mummy I don't know he looks like
did that but didn't work well because
you have to do it for years
welcome are you just sucking your cheeks
or is it like you just want your tongue
holder so say say the word sing sing so
where's your tongue or your tongue ends
at the roof and then you bring the tip
to the top so it's like singing and you
close your mouth so like one of the
things as a mouth breeders that was like
a batter for you without breathing with
their mouths open and then from that
like over time they develop like smaller
jobs because or like not really
developing like just your jaw muscles
don't work like this are you doing that
for yourself or are you doing that to
get the ladies only for the least if
it's myself I wouldn't give a [ __ ] about
any girls are just so damn forgiving
that we don't even have to be that good
for my confidence for the girls anyways
my blue nails I'm just trying to do it
right now it's put your tongue in the
roof of your mouth and that's it and
then you kind of do like a little
suction so it stays there and you just
close your mouth and you only breathe
throughout your nose your teeth have to
be closed though you don't to much if
you're if you're clenching your jaw
clenching just like but you don't want
to be like this you don't be like this
you know what is like you have a
dope-ass jaw line but you only have
three teeth thing you have a dope-ass
darling you get or like if you you get
what you want but then you're cursed got
something else happens than Elsa there's
way that which one would you rather have
this cosmetic dentistry I like teeth all
right that more teeth in that Akula Java
it's like a to better I'd rather have a
cool dollar
yeah I'd hold y'all and just get some
fake teeth
you can't eat steak I'm talking about
like if you can only choose one or the
other and then you can do anything
afterwards never yeah she stuck with
duty for the rest of your life give a
[ __ ] about eating so I could just have
smoothies further similar have a great
dot line three teeth on the top though
it's not like a baby with you on top and
one on the bottom this and then in a
great job line oh that's pretty bad well
your jaw line though get a job [ __ ]
don't
yeah I really you have the good jaw line
than me so we're good so what do you do
okay okay so this guy he's an actor like
we said he apparently uh choked a fan
huh choke a [ __ ] fat joke think is so
funny don't you think like out of all
the attacks slapping punching but
choking gotta be committed both has the
attacker as the victim both someone
being choked it's pretty funny watching
someone choking you with like the kill
in their eyes I'm like oh I would be
laughing while I'm dying this is my
dream I think it's funny because it's uh
it's you're in at least like a sixty
second commitment yeah in a passionate
like Hannity my grandma action is
violence but then when I'm like when I'm
this in a matter night you still don't
and he's just looking at me and we're
looking at each other eyes it's kind of
intimate yeah what kind of intimate for
like 60 second it could be kind of
sexual too so just know it's kind of
funny too I don't know I don't know I
like choking during sex but not during a
fight anyway so here's a video clip of
him choking us I don't want to break her
she comes at him kind of like playfully
like not even that much though I don't
get it does she have a turtleneck on
so just protection there in rectally Oh
Iceland Iceland Iceland right yeah yeah
that one anyway there they are at a bar
okay that's a bar that looks like a
[ __ ] oh it was so well lit where I
was like doesn't work that look like
don't watch the video that is outside
you know that's outside yeah [ __ ] over
there
I thought Boyz R Us so what happened
here there's multiple things that are
being said around this but the official
report is that he is not under any
criminal investigation because there
were rumors on Twitter saying like yeah
he choked out this fan he was such a
dick this fan was just trying to say hi
and they look like they're played looks
like they are both in on it but that
night it got so crazy that cops had to
come and they escorted him out because
he was being so violent and he even spit
at someone and blah blah blah please
make up new [ __ ] right that's so funny
the police said that the officers were
never called they didn't kalus of the
alleged altercation and there were no
injuries reported to the police so no
one was arrested a known displace in
custody like that's the official report
of it but apparently they're saying that
he was confronted by a bunch of fans and
the bar staff escorted him off the
premises and there were other rumors on
Twitter saying that like the other side
of it was that he was just there with
his friends at the barge chillin and
then these fans just came up to him and
they were being a little aggressive and
then that's when he kind of just got fed
up at that point and that's when he came
out the
like that wanna fight so we don't know
what the true story is because there's
all these rumors very violent either a
lot of what I heard was he was drunk so
a lot of what I heard was he was super
drunk and they kicked him out of the bar
because he was drunk and he was I
talking back to like the staff there but
then before I guess that video happened
was he lost Carl him because he's always
and he was bragging about getting all
these fights and I show them all the
scars and then she was like oh I could
beat you up and then that's when that
was recorded and then that's when he
grabbed her it's funny because if I am
getting any aggression from fans the
first person I wouldn't choose is a girl
fan to beat up you know I mean like it
does it's difficult for me to be
aggressive toward females like it's not
the same yeah little sister feel like I
don't know it's different than like a
guy fan I feel like I could [ __ ] his ass
up there's a lot of people commenting
too from what I read that I like as
ramela he identifies as non-binary
people are getting mad that whole hid
the fact that he's on binary makes it
like I guess like they're like well I
guess he chose to fight oh girl which is
okay since he's non-binary that means
that means at that moment he was a girl
at that moment rose to be a girl so does
that mean if I identify as a woman and I
get into a fight with the woman then
that's okay does it make sense it's not
okay defy anyone ever yeah I like that
but I think I think the only bad guy
here is the one with the camera because
why would you shut off the camera at the
most exciting part you ran out of
storage
it's like fix your [ __ ] framing dude
oh they shut the camera off to help ya
keep it all in there not a vlogger but I
heard I heard a lot
you would like yeah it's on Twitter a
whole bunch of [ __ ] like from before and
stuff like that and wreck your Vic Rick
how you say it again
I don't know right Iceland yeah but like
in that city in particular that he
frequents it a lot and that people from
that city this is the hate is that what
I read on Twitter so I don't know how
true it is don't make me have to
recommend but yeah that apparently they
just they don't like him because he's an
[ __ ]
you're drunk [ __ ] is he Italy from the
states like we're in there again yeah
he's American he's from New Jersey
but yeah so then there were other
stories like the like screenshots of DMS
from people who have interacted with him
like this one particular girl was saying
like yeah he was such an [ __ ] like I
met him once and he I didn't know who he
was he was so offended that I don't know
who he was and he ended up like and then
my boyfriend showed him a video that he
did and said like oh yeah we could work
on something together if you ever need
it and then that he's the the actor said
oh I don't need to work with you I have
way more followers than you all just
take your idea and do it myself and like
apparently they're all worries about him
we don't know how true they are but
that's what was being said on Twitter of
like how how he's well known to be an
ass counsel you gotta cancel it for like
I forgot what I was like some movie or
something he did where he like Grodin
but I was like basically stolen no no
but it was like something about like
like the police violence but just
basically like in a bad way showing like
how the cops are like in the right are
good for doing that oh yeah this one
twig is like when the police shoot
minorities they're in the right if you
made a movie about that yeah yeah is
once we've caption that's that video I
showed you guys eyes ivory watched this
video of Ezra Miller choking a woman
like 50 times laughs my [ __ ] ass off
this is y'all tone deaf tone deaf cop
sympathizing
style stealing narcissistic white icon a
long list of goodies there it is funny
how people just take I mean this is a
[ __ ] you don't know what really happen
or you could even be that chick could
even be like can you please I do this to
me guys wanted you to do cuz I I
my fans like meet and greets and delight
Bart can you pick me up for a picture or
heap Iceland gonna arm wrestle me so
there's a no I guess like all the people
around or seems to be reacting pretty
negatively so but you know what like
what Joe said though like which is most
people's reaction I think what which is
like well we don't know we're really
happy and like we don't have the whole
story like we can't really judge it off
of this 7 second clip but then you
expressing that like that that your
opinion of that people are attacking
that and saying how the [ __ ] you not
like you have enough information to make
up your mind like how can you even
because do you see me with a Captain
Crunch outfit in a [ __ ] gavel like a
damn judge [ __ ] dude
do you see one of these [ __ ]
[ __ ] court that's why the [ __ ] and
if he was I have all the evidence I
could make a clear decision
alright magistrate why don't you become
a [ __ ] judge then
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]